[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 147 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Melanie Warrick and I'm here with
special co-hosts Billy rink and yelling
Brucie hello Billy hello yelling hi I'm
Melanie it's nice to be here thank you
for being here all right I'm gonna have
you both take a quick minute and tell us
a little bit about who you are
thanks I'm Billy I am a lecturer at
Stellenbosch University this is of
course also the hosts for the series
deep learning in Doba I have a passion
for machine learning computer vision I
have a passion for teaching and it is
wonderful for me to be here I'm glad
you're here knowing ya I'm Yellin
Morrises melanie has mentioned I
recently joined the Google AI team for
the group that's gonna be played that's
gonna be in Accra Ghana I'm very excited
about that before that I was a
researcher at the Council for scientific
and industrial research countries it's a
very very long name but it's a research
lab here in South Africa government
funded and also partially industry I'm
very very excited to be going to Accra
because I can continue to a
machine-learning and continue living in
Africa which is exactly where we are
here at the endeavor yes we are doing
this recording in this episode
specifically is about deep learning in
Java where we're going to showcase a
couple of interviews that we captured
during this week can you both take a
minute and just tell the audience what
deep learning adop is about our line is
strengthening Africa machine learning so
it's good to start with us but I think
the deep learning in Java has become
strengthening African machine learning
but I think when we started it we did
not know exactly how much it would and
it has become a community of sharing
knowledge of sharing skill of
celebrating one another and of course
continual learning so it almost feels
like it's gonna be our yearly pilgrimage
where from wherever we come from we go
to wherever everybody is and we
collaborate and we work together and we
just we catch help and we celebrate what
we did with the last year yeah and I
think also what is very important for us
is to equip students and academics from
all over Africa to come together to meet
each other to
work but very importantly also to go
back to their own communities and carry
on this message of strengthening machine
learning and yeah really just catching
up with the rest of the world Africa has
enormous potential and I think it's a
very exciting time for all of us
great well as I mentioned we have some
interviews in this episode in particular
we are going to be talking with and Vili
you helped me with this we're talking
about the Essene and we are also talking
with Cosi and we're going to spend part
of that interview really talking a
little bit more about what deep learning
in Davos is about and some of the awards
that were given out and then the other
part of our interview that was covered
was with Andrea whose VC here in Africa
and I know yelling and I just spoke with
her and had a great conversation so
before we get into our interviews as
always we start out with some of the
cool things of the week and a question
of the week and we're gonna wrap up with
a question that is pretty much what are
some of our key takeaways from the
conference but as I mentioned we'd like
to start out with the cool thing of the
week and we're gonna do a little
variation off of this which is to help
talk a little bit about sort of one of
some of the highlights that have been
going on not the key takeaways but
things that have been happening during
this conference where some of the great
things that have been going on or
activities like I know that we've had a
lot of speakers here and yeah so we've
really had an action-packed week great
speakers Nando de Freitas was here and
Mustafa sees and lots of others David
silver Jeff Dean so it's a really really
great list of speakers we also had
poster sessions which were amazing all
the students presenting their own work
movie screenings of alphago right there
was a woman in machine learning event
one evening which was really inspiring
you were speaking at that one as well
yeah and it was a very well attended I
was wonderful our biggest sessions and
then there's been students who are from
all over different countries within
Africa
my understanding is like 30 countries
and the number of attendees is around
550 attendees that's right
outside of the will of nth I think one
of the cool things that I saw was when
David silver walked in and somebody was
sitting there and looked over and saw
him it was like oh my god I just saw you
in a movie I thought that was pretty fun
to watch any other little highlights are
coming to mind I think I also saw
somebody one down at David Silva
spotting and
he kinda lost his mind a little bit the
cool events oh goodness
they are just so many my coolest event
was the award sessions and the posters
are always really rewarding and
enlightening and half the time I mean
you just go there to just learn meeting
all the other people that are actually
machining and maybe that's actually
something to mention about the number of
people that have traveled from far other
researchers have jam-packed a schedule
that travels from far to come spend the
week with us and that's been very
exciting to see them all so very much so
any posters that jump out oh well this
is really putting me on the spot because
the one poster that I do remember was
actually Steve Crone and Herman Herman
is also your colleague who go organize
this and this poster will be at nips
this year's nips poster and they have a
closure they have discovered about how
to add noise in a network so how much
noise can you add in a network until you
can't learn anymore
so actually you saturate the network and
you cannot anymore then in a deep net
and so they have these closure
properties about how deep you can go and
how much noise you can add and that's
really beautiful because so much I mean
that just narrows the parameter tuning
search space I mean this is work that's
been done right here in Stellenbosch
that's great well I think it's time for
us to go ahead and jump into our
interview so let's go do that today I'm
excited to have with me dr. Volkow see
my bath a and Yaseen Musa a Yami who are
both here at deep learning and Abba
which is based in celibate South Africa
for this edition of the deep learning in
Taba and with me also is Lilly brink who
is helping to be my special guest
co-host so thank you all for coming
today okay thank you now let me go ahead
and kick us off like we usually do which
is to have you tell us a little bit
about who you are so if a Cosi can you
start thank you for having me over my
background most deep is in kind of
machine learning at the moment I am the
chair of data science and a senior
lecturer at the University of Victoria
taking through my background interested
in a kind of machine learning in AI from
a young age ended up going to university
of advancement in Johannesburg
ding Electrical Engineering
then undergone a master's degree from
them we've done to do a PhD in computer
science focus on enforcement learning in
New Jersey at Rutgers University when
that was kind of ending off decided that
I wanted to go into data science because
I was very interested in some of the
kind of it's being dynamic and looking
at different methods for lots of
different areas and then came back to
South Africa settled at the Council for
scientific and industrial research for
about three and a half years or so
working in data science and that's how I
also got kind of roughed in much into
the deep learning is roped in they found
you and then they made you come and do
this oh good to know
and you seen can you tell us a little
bit about your background my name is
Alison Messiah me I'm a background in
the is in software engineering I did my
undergrad at the University of
Technology in I graduated with BT
Camelot and then a later own kind of
transition to the field of AI I was my
area of research was computer vision so
besides that I'm also an a certified
Orrico associate also I'm the co-founder
and CTO at so go low-tech and yeah my
vision has always been to kind of
leverage take for social good thanks
that's great well so the reason why
we're doing this recording specifically
is because we wanted to touch on two
things that are playing out one you know
deep running in Java and what it's about
as well as the math I award that is at
deep learning and Dabo which you seen I
know you had one
we were actually just talking about it
today so let me go ahead and kick off
with first like what is deep learning in
dhaba tell us a little bit about what is
this conference where did it come from
what do you know about it why are you
doing this because II and so being
facetious about being roped in it was a
good group of friends and acquaintances
who came together after one I guess a
number of iterations of if you went in
to some of the big machine learning and
kind of neuroscience or data mining
conferences seeing the lack of
participation from the African continent
is something that was
I think concerning and not more honest
people have papers they're really but on
I think from my view that those people
are missing out that there's a lot
that's going on on the continent there's
a lot of very interesting areas that
people are working on that might not be
seen maybe if you're sitting in in a
Google or Microsoft and in Europe or in
the US that you might not think about
but then people are trying to resolve so
through like a number of conversations I
knew a lot of the co-organizers
personally before and we started talking
about this and saying can't we do
something in terms of trying to grow
machine learning and its visibility on
the continent not that it's not there
but if we could find a way to bring
people together come share their work
their expertise build a network and get
this to kind of snowball into something
that's going to be much bigger than just
us so they in da by that it really
encompasses that in that we're trying to
strengthen African machine learning and
by doing that it's building the the
community in itself as one way of doing
that learning from each other offering
each other like you know each other's
skills to the community and seeing how
like in a way this is going to get us in
kind of a couple of years so even though
this is the second yeah it is still like
the beginning and you mentioned it's the
second year last year being the first
year where was last year last year was
at the University of Atlantis Toronto
vets University has its own in
Johannesburg and that was about three
hundred and thirty people from 22
different African countries nice and
this year it's around five fifty fifty
yeah as a target nice well when you
mentioned community I know we were
talking actually before we started
recording about how there's all these
deep learning in Java X events and
community building activities that have
been happening throughout different
countries within Africa and so seeing I
know you are one of the organizers and
specifically you organized one in Zambia
and when was that that you organized on
between 4th of March ok and what was
that like in terms of organizing the
event there it was a bit challenging
I know organizing the endeavor exits
idea because one was the issue of
resources having spent most of my time
in South Africa in
organizing things here I was assuming
that it's gonna be the same that I did
but when I got there I literally had to
pay for everything including venues
computers and things like that so when
we kind of advertise for people to kind
of register for the entire hex we
received a number of applications but
sadly because due to the number of
resources we could only accommodate a
few ends who only accumulated about 60
participants and other participants and
50 when we could not accommodate them
and mostly if you look at the expenses
that we incurred you know the expenses
that when you're supposed to being cut
it was like you're looking at something
that you want to empower people you want
to give knowledge to people you want to
produce a cohort of youth that are
technologically empowered so we're
trying to associate it to universities
but when we approach universities they
were not open to the idea you know bowls
they were looking at it from a marketing
perspective I mean they were talking
about issues to do with okay if you want
to partner with us come with at least 50
participants so that in a way was
difficult from our end because we
couldn't kind of like provide for the
150 people so we ended up like resorting
to having other venues which was not
supposed to be the case well well for
the event okay so what went well is the
positive feedback we got from people so
people now are saying let's make this an
annual thing whether deplaning endeavor
is in deep learning in he is not in so
we've got also some good responses from
corporate people and we're hoping that
more would bind to the idea so like
we've had people you know coming to us
and saying okay well you never reached
out to us and we're like no the people
that you've employed to kind of let us
have access to you wait denying us
access to you sometimes would send
emails but you you are not responding to
our emails but at least now we've kind
of established contact with these people
and we are able to contact them directly
so going forward I think the subsequent
endeavors will be bigger and better and
obviously we'll have
more and more people coming on board so
the next endeavor we're hoping to have
at least maybe 150 or more people and
yeah so arising from the deplaning in
Java there's some monthly tutorials that
aim at you know in increasing the number
of people that are in this area of data
science and yeah so we're hoping that as
the population grows of people in data
science then setting issues you can have
a number of people working on various
issues that being affected in the
country what's going well and what are
some of the challenges that you've seen
for Cosi from working on d planning a
dhaba the biggest challenge is order
demand very common to what you've seen
the thing yeah yes nothing offer I think
we're going back to the beginning of the
in dhaba we had envisioned I think 50
well even in the first year
why was the way we were planning for and
we ended up getting like 700
applications and by then I think we were
thinking okay let's just make it 200 so
by the time some hundred applications
came in it was behind you 200 we need to
increase this as much as possible so
it's something that we have to come to
terms with and it's like again it's it's
this thing of saying that things are
happening people the wanting to do more
in this area the amount of times you
talk to professionals students even
academics who come up and say look yeah
I'm doing Y or X but I'm actually very
interested in machine learning and
artificial intelligence because I have
this idea and I think if I can just
grasp the methods I will be able to
actually do something with it that's
what they endeavor is for and the kind
of knock on czar still something that I
think we're still having a very hard
time being able to quantify so just from
what you see me saying of saying now you
have monthly events and every time you
meet the index organizers is there's
always a story about this is other
things that we actually started doing
afterwards and being able to empower
them to continue into their journeys is
also important because it's like you
know we as then the Manian double
organizers can only do so much you know
you know you can only
so many so even with the first year only
having three on him 30 being at the main
event in Johannesburg the Indaba axis
actually then had a total over a
thousand over that March and April
period so you can see that the you know
that's a big effect in terms of doing
that and yes it does bring in more
people more demand again to us because
then people want to come for the that's
yeah that's a good problem right yes
that is a good problem on there and yes
for us we try to keep the mission being
the main thing the strengthening of
African machine learning as being what
we want people to sign on for so in
working to get sponsors or get partners
maybe not yeah we want them to buy into
that mission yeah and if it's not the
thing that they or they want to do it's
like you know we understand but it's
this cornerstone that we need to keep
because that's why people come here they
said over six days and little sleep
going through a lot of content talking
to each other like you get amazed at
kind of some of the connections that
there are a significant amount of
content that's definitely being covered
at this conference so I can understand
that and the fact that there's monthly
tutorials that are also being produced
it's also kind of incredible and frankly
I heard someone saying how they were
amazed at how much people are just
engaged it's so wonderful to see how
much engagement there is how much
excitement there is about what's being
shared so thank you well okay so let's
get into the fact that there's two wards
that were given out and some honorable
mentions in relation to those wards and
I know the mitai award in particular was
given out and it was really to recognize
along the lines of you know even people
who are individuals especially who can
have large impacts in the world around
them especially in the ways that they
approach problems that they're solving
is that doing it pseudo justice I know
it's probably not doing a full justice
but could you expand a little bit more
on that because it was a price to
recognize innovation using machine
learning we I across the continent so
where there was a group an individual it
didn't matter but we wanted to see what
people were doing out there I think you
see me completely embodies this where
you go off and you have the societal
challenge that that is out there and you
think about what is an approach that I
could use to try and tackle this right
and then you go backwards and then you
find something that's kind
of tangible and then you say okay I need
to now use this tool and learn and see
how I can innovate around it to be able
to then kind of get people where they
are as opposed to chrome like you know a
I've got this hammer I need to hit nails
and I'm looking out for nails and I
think that's what the mitai award is
about so let's talk about what you're
working on it's a goal attempt okay so
so gonna take is a tech startup that
aims at making use of state-of-the-art
technology to kind of contributes to add
solving these socio-economic problems
that we're currently facing so among
them is the issues of cholera issues
with financial inclusion like
underserved communities how can we
include them in the form of financial
sector what made me Whitney Mota impact
a lot was the app that we created to
cook up which aims at automating
transactions what happens is women in
and the developed areas have resorted to
coming up with village bank so village
banks is this kind of a system which
enables people that are living in the
same area contribute money then from
that money that they contribute then
they able to lend it out amongst
themselves and then they able to pay
back interest so what was happening is
of course that was a good idea but the
challenge was the transactions that
occurred during this process were done
on paper so we kind of thought that if
we kind of automate this process and
once we to make this process then we'll
have data data we can use for many
things among things that can be done
with this data is approach banks because
you find that these areas maybe do not
have a bank so you can go to a bank and
then say ok see these people are making
X amount of savings and I think these
people needs a branch or something like
that again since this issue of
cryptocurrency the blockchain that
making waves on the Internet I mean how
can we even innovators come up with ways
in which we can use these technologies
to kind of aid these people in managing
their transactions so that's what this
app was all about and we visit to kind
of by 2019 to reach out to about 22,000
women
well why women okay well if you look at
the stats Financial Inclusion stats in
Zambia about 41% of adults are
financially excluded and majority of
which are women and most of these rural
dwellers so that's the reason why we
mostly looking at these people because
these are people who may be going to do
selling items farming so the NICU that
they are making if it's not properly
managed then they end up having nothing
so I think that's what kind of made us
focus mainly on women that's wonderful
in the app itself can you tell us a
little bit about that and how it
functions what kind of technology are
you using okay so we had created a
prototype a mobile app it's called coo
coo coo cachoo t : so which enabled
these people to kind of enter the
transactions on this app and then
obviously it was some patent application
that was storing the data so now what we
observed is the literacy levels are very
low also the financial literacy levels
are also low so you find that we issues
in terms of recording these transactions
and you find that somebody cannot write
record the transactions so they had
maybe to depend on somebody to record
for them transactions consequently
somebody might end up maybe recording
room transactions or one is not able to
track their own transactions so if we
kind of automate this process we thought
this could somehow you know knock out
some of these issues so that's the
reason why we created that but since
these people have low literacy levels
it's been difficult to kind of make use
of the app and looking at the internet
levels the penetration of internet
levels it's still not that much
so we're thinking of now integrating the
SMS system so we want to use USSD for
them to record this transactions instead
of using the mobile app then
subsequently after we've got these
transactions automated we're looking at
making use of state-of-the-art machine
learning
deplaning to kind of help these people
build a credit profile those if you go
to a bank obviously do need some form of
collateral for you to get a loan I know
the people that do not have access to
banks right and of course meaning they
do not have access to loans just as an
example by doing if you've been
following the news we've had like three
infernals in the last couple of years
which happened to think two months ago
famous camisa market which houses people
from the commercial region so you've got
people from Tanzania people from Malawi
you've got people from Zimbabwe
so those and infinity and people lost
goods with other master so you find that
that was the only source of livelihood
and there couldn't be compensated they
were looking up to the government to
kind of compensate them but you know the
government couldn't and so these people
have just resorted to staying at home so
Zambia being a country the third world
country that is striving to fight
poverty I don't think it's possible to
fight poverty if that's the case so
we're hoping that if the up is excessive
then we can help them build a credit
profile and then subsequently link them
maybe to for more financial institutions
like the banks where there may be able
to access loans both oh of course you
know with village banks they're able to
get loans but it's only a limited amount
of money both the contributions it's
maybe one dollar two dollars so if let's
say somebody wants a loan of maybe a
thousand dollars so you find that maybe
the group cannot sustain that the amount
of savings that they've got cannot save
is that so if we built the credit
profile then subsequently these people
will be able to kind of good approach
the banks and then the banks will be
able maybe to give these people loans so
that's what we're aiming at and
obviously there's been a lot of research
that's been going on I mean attending in
dava we talked about 550 in majority of
which are resettles
so if you carry out a random survey and
I don't think this maybe anybody that's
maybe working in a Financial Inclusion
space or to be specific somebody working
on this village up think one of the
reasons could be the issue of data so
we're hoping that if we generate this
data we can then push it to the public
so people can make use of it and then
do some research and of course we
accompany Sentra fact that is the issues
of ethics that have to be considered so
that's why we're heading towards so in
terms of the data itself you said you're
storing it currently what are you
storing it on well we're just selling it
online we've got a back-end application
that storing the data and of course we
going to use some API is to kind of
expose the data if we want to use it for
machine learning
Samuel is it an app that exists
currently or is it's a prototype
prototype it but it's not yet in the
market I mean we just testing not got it
what are you prototyping it on is it on
like an iOS or whose an iOS app used
some Microsoft tools I don't if I'm
allowed to kind of make it I was using
the Marines a Marine enables you to
create cross-platform app okay so with
circular take we don't necessarily have
in-house developers so mostly its people
who've good time and are willing to
spend the time working on social issues
so it was one of my friend Janine that
was actually working on the app were
actually collaborating I was doing minor
changes the end but she did most of the
work end with me I was focused when
creating the backend right
and obviously providing her the
necessary API that would enable her to
consume for the app functionality nice
what are your future plans my future
plans are to tackle as many problems as
possible of course
offline we were talking about the issue
of cholera in the next three months
there will be another disaster
I presume abuse there's nothing that has
been done from the last time we
encountered this problem the issue of
cholera
so I'm trying to also kind of see if we
can tap into that also to see how we can
use existing data to kind of reduce the
number of cases that are recorded and
subsequently reduce the numbers of
deaths that are recorded so those are
some of the plans and yeah also to get
as many local developers as possible I
don't know I don't
see it appropriate for local developers
to kind of contribute to offshore
projects and get up when we've got a lot
of issues that have to be tackled in
house at Cigala we are fortunate to kind
of have two groups of people one
engineers and others are people that are
working in development awake
so these people working in development
away kind of pointers to areas where
which need attention
they tell us okay this I think this
needs a problem so we engage the
engineers who kind of come up with a
tech solution that can tackle this
problem so we're hoping to have as many
local developers as possible
helping towards achieving this scope do
you accept support from external
developers that are not you know is that
something that you do currently or you
want to do well I think it's something
that we'd want to do you know
collaborate with external developers I
mean on Saturday I'm actually living
today I'm living for Germany so with
Germany we're going for a sailing
program that's more like an incubation
program so they kind of walk you through
the stages of developing a product and
of course listening to the public and of
course ways you can manage that product
so it's basically aimed at startups and
then seeing how they can kind of sustain
the status what happens is if good
startup that is in existence for a few
months two years then it just disappears
right well that's great about the
startup incubator in Germany and then in
terms of if somebody's listening to us
and they want to help or they want to
you know participate in terms of what
you're building how would they do that
so they can reach out to us but
definitely have your contact information
because the issue is we've not been able
to do much because we just rely on
people that are already working so they
can only work on certain projects when
they are free if we could have you know
proper funding to kind of have in-house
maybe
data scientist software engineers we
will be able to work on these problems
more quickly you know because the issue
with tech is like they say the only
thing with technology that does not
change is that it's always changing
maybe today I might be
King about okay we want to make use of
cryptocurrencies and blockchain to
tackle this issue of financial inclusion
tomorrow it is something else
so what's I'm still working on this then
it becomes in a way obsolete so I just
have to stop because the feel
demotivated our goal is to come up with
ways in which we can quickly work on
these problems and then may be deployed
republic and then see if challenges that
people are facing analyzing whether this
problem is solving the problem that
we're trying to solve then also trying
to identify ways in which we can improve
on the product that sounds great
well thank you before we wrap up what I
want to touch on is you know what are
some of the key things that you've
you're taking away from the deep
learning and ah before this week what
are some things that you've experienced
so far that have been really valuable
for you in terms of what you've seen
just sort of touching on what you're
seeing has been talking about my agenda
knowledge over to Pinterest starting out
especially in data science is to do data
science that comes from a social bent so
coming from social impact as a space so
I'll be very happy to like you know have
more conversations about how do we go
from that data find ways to release it
in the proper way for researchers to be
able to use and for us like you know at
places like the University of Pretoria
be able to work with students to
actually build on research in that space
because yes the on one part day is data
the other is experts like you see me
over there and this is also as permeated
the in dhaba if you go in and you see
the posters and you see what people
actually presenting and the things that
they're working on you kind of yeah he
starts seeing threads of oh this could
turn into something bigger if you could
get like you know one two three four
people together from these different
countries right you know we we shouldn't
look at our borders and say that's where
we end I think the in dhaba is trying to
reduce that that distance and allow
people to be able to work across and be
able to mentor other like you know
mentor students mentor professionals
across this border so I'm hoping that is
the thing that is gonna go on I've seen
examples of people doing this after
meeting especially another meeting not
like you know saying advertising at data
science Africa I did meet people last
year as a
my trying to cover as much of the
continent as possible and bring people
in just like we met I know and I was
saying this offline that I know about
this conference because of you Foucault
see because you were at a conference
that I was at and you spoke about it and
I mean it was like how do I get involved
so exactly I was not a science Africa
trying to bring like you know talk about
the story like you know sure about my
research but also that we're having
named Dava that led to we have one of
our Corgan eise's Kathleen who actually
I met that data science Africa and I had
a gentleman that I got to that mentor
this year working on disease modeling in
Malawi just having like you know a few
Skype meetings it's not this like you
know people think like Oh mentoring
means you're spending but then trying to
reduce that and being able to enough
I've seen people like Benjamin Grossman
do kind of the same thing yeah and maybe
I can just add that Africa as a
continent has so many problems that are
unique to the continent and it is very
important for us to equip our students
to be able to deal with these problems
and hopefully the Indaba also go some
way towards that goal that's great and I
know that the sessions that are being
held right now are being recorded and
that will be released do you guys know
when that's going to be released we're
hoping for
very soon off to the end Alba might be
over the weekend or early next week
great and oh and you were going to say
something else
it also again speaks to this methods of
sharing whether somebody's at they in
dava or not to get as much of the
content as possible so there's a lot of
work that has gone into the practical
sessions and all of that is on github
already and people can go in to interact
with it I think get the links free yeah
yeah I keep on saying we're trying to
manufacture abundance this is it's not
about reducing access all right so it's
increasing it so making sure that
there's videos there's the practical
sessions and the practical sessions also
all that content is available yes
sometimes it does go down when it goes
down it's because it's being improved
it's not that we're removing it from and
that's what happened we know we switched
off last year's practicals you then
start getting messages with people
asking you
can we have access we were actually just
waiting for the switchover to this
year's which is like you know practicals
which are much better yeah I've heard
wonderful commentary and people seeing
the practicals and and having wonderful
experiences with them and next year deep
learning Adama is going to be in Kenya
do you know where Kenyatta University in
Nairobi Kenya
nice the good news is also that we were
again trying to increase the numbers
quite substantially so please look out
for the call for applications for next
year's edition great anything else that
you wanted to talk about or make sure we
cover before we go so I just wanted to
add one what we and of course yes about
you know issues to do with the problems
that we're facing as a continent so one
problem that we're facing as Africans is
when we get people like Gugu
when they approach us so we leave Africa
and then go stay in Europe in terms of
making progress right trend I mean in a
way retro grazing yeah so we're not
making any changes to whatever problems
that we're facing so I think off let's
yes we've got we've had issues where
you've had to hire experts from Europe
to come and solve our problems here in
Africa and of course I don't know for
lack of village about say an oxymoron to
say that okay we've got this
unemployment in Africa on the other hand
you also seen people do work for you
people so I think right now since a is
still in its infancy if we can get as
many as much people as possible into
this space of AI so that instead of
outsourcing people from Europe through
government solve our issues I think we
should be the better people to kind of
tackle our issues I think we understand
them better like we all know you know
you cannot compare an original vision to
a translated version so I'd like to
recommend the week that these guys like
Shakira and other guys that are working
in London who you know of course the
good jobs there but they did not forget
about this African continent and of
course decided to come up with deplaning
in Taba and of course sacrificing their
time the efforts in trying to make this
thing a success from this favor and
50 participants you can just imagine how
many more people are going to benefit
obviously people are went back to the
communities with feedback and of course
the deplaning now exists I think it was
in 13 countries the previous one so
we've got about 22 African countries
so I'm hoping that in 22 African
countries plus there will be some sort
of an index and then if the in the index
is usually held around much if we can
have like total participants for this
index like even more than hundred
thousand so I think it would be a great
place to me so like we didn't just say
that okay they trying to increase the
number of people that I want to
participate in the deplaning in dhaba so
people don't necessarily need to attend
the deplaning in Java the main one but
through this smooth deepening in dawa
access browser of course there is the
issues of funding so you have to fly
people from Cameroon people from Egypt
to come and attend in Java so that in a
way would kind of limit you in terms of
doing certain things so if we can
identify people that we can train
properly and of course run these
endeavors in respective countries I
think that would be more effective so as
I was organizing the deplaning in Nava X
one of the issues that I faced was the
issues to do it speakers do a few
speakers
I knew off that could deliver talks at
the deplaning in directs one of which is
a singer he's here who's invited to come
and to do sessions mats tutorials so if
we can also build capacity in that area
to increase the number of people that
can also float this content to other
people I think also would be heading
towards the right direction so I don't
know if we can have endeavour just so
she has designed to claim people to come
sort of a trainer of trainers yeah which
yes you know when we talk about indirect
Zambia we know exactly that look at this
X Y & Z booze one is having an endeavor
X in Zambia but two is also having
people who are able to like deliver
content to these participants and then
of course having this participants
benefit from the tutorials that will be
given by this participant this is great
and thank you and
thing else that you guys wanted to touch
on before we go the thing I've been
parroting over the last few days of just
over and over again is is going to be
that yes we are getting to a point where
we we have to think about how how do we
grow scaling definitely on our minds as
organizers and trying to figure out
what's the best way at the same time we
aren't ignorant of the fact of a lot of
other initiatives that I have been
kicked off her head kicked off a little
bit earlier than us or have kicked off
after we had started even here in South
Africa so those a lot going on in this
week in this area there in terms of
machine learning so and just think about
the continent so how do we come together
as this wider community it's strong and
then then be stronger yes it's it's not
about us that I think I'll keep on
saying to my co organizers that it's not
about us it's going to be about the
community and to do this we're gonna
have to come together and come up with a
strategy on how we bring in all these
resources that we have there might be
minor and the biggest scheme of things
but we still have to optimize them to
deliver well and through this if we can
connect them together a fine way for
people to move in and around it builds a
much better stronger community of
practice right now there's International
Data week that will be happening in
Botswana in November I am hosting a
session their thoughts are for good
specifically to try and find a given
more people who work in here like you
know create TVs honey pots of people who
submit some abstract and then you'll go
in and say oh we didn't even know that
you like you know people in your area
act like you know doing this so maybe
you should also come in and and think so
that community building still has to go
on and let me also end on this point if
people are interested in getting
involved you know whether it's
participating in the actual conference
whether it's providing resources you
know whatever it is how do they get in
touch who did they get in touch with at
the moment I think on the website we've
set up a link to try and get as much
information about researchers
practitioners professionals and the
continent in machine learning in E and
data science so you can go and actually
sign up and submit a form we're trying
to keep track we have a mailing list
that people can sign up for they can
send messages through that in terms of
for the community that's connected to
the in dawa and beyond
that's what the the ambition kind of
there and be the website there is a
contact and if you send an email to that
they will then get in touch with us
directly we all man all the organizers
actually man the email so somebody will
respond to you quickly in terms of what
you can do so the website is the like
lightning rod and you will get all this
information there great of course II you
seen Billy thank you all for joining me
today I really appreciate it
thanks Manny thank you thank you today
I'm very happy that Andrea beaumart is
here with us and I have special guest
co-host with me yelling Morosi who I
know she's looking at my notes because I
wrote down her name and I didn't write
down the right spelling but I wrote and
so I can read it anyways thank you both
for being here
beau thank you very much for having us
you're here because we're at deep
learning in da Bob and you are here to
give us a perspective from the VC
perspective in Africa in particular can
you tell us a little bit about you and
your background sure absolutely
so as you can hear from my accent I'm
not originally from South Africa I'm
from Germany after finishing University
there I came to South Africa of an
internship and kind of state so that's
not 20 something years ago so I've spent
the last of my professional life
actually all in South Africa first few
years working for a big corporate and
now since 12 years actually in the
venture capital investment space here in
South Africa
thank you well so what is the deep
learning in dhaba conference been like
for you so far this week is actually
very very interesting week I was
unfortunately only able to be here for
the first day for the opening day
because at the same time in Cape Town we
have three other conferences kind of
happening so I'm actually very very
excited to be it I must say so far I've
been very very impressed with a few
things first of all the sheer quantity
of people the whole diversity the fact
that they're people I think from 33
countries here and very honestly I was
quite impressed by the number of females
normally one kind of things data
scientist that this is still a very very
heavily male-dominated kind of and I was
very positively surprised quite a few
women actually are here and I love the
communication the level of communication
I thought that data scientists are
introverts apparently they are not today
she talked we are introverts yeah so I
actually think we might have a mix of
some extroverts and
traverse but I think we work well
together I thought everybody would just
stand there looking down quietly and I
walked around it everybody was chatting
so I think that's amazing that's great
my understanding is that you are one of
the biggest investors in AI in Africa is
that statement correct well so let's put
it like this I think we are one of the
oldest VC funds here and yes we've
always done tech investments and we have
done an investment in a AI company I
think it's quite interesting because not
many African investors have so far
invested in AI or machine learning kind
of companies a number of international
have if I want to talk about I'll be one
of the very few Africans like South
African investors who have invested in
AI companies and yes absolutely
you know you mentioned something about
the number of women that you've seen
here how as the number of the women in
the VC especially in your area of
investing in AI in Africa are you just
the one data point yeah yes now I think
I'm not the one data point but I think
in and I can actually not really talk
about the African I have to refer to the
South African but I think in South
Africa there are maybe three four female
investment partners yes it's a very
heavily male-dominated world but it
isn't-- we are working on it from what
you're saying why is it that not as many
VCS and in the African continent are
doing investments in AI in Africa I
think first of all you should invest in
things that you understand and now
before you know ask me whether I
understand AI that's a different story
but I think a lot of people are a little
bit scared because a is currently used
in close to every pitch there's a lot of
hype about it
there's buzzword bingo absolutely around
it if I look at the business plans have
come across my table I would say every
second has got a word like AI or ml
somewhere in the business plan which
doesn't mean that they're really doing
it and I think a lot of investors trap
scared to fall for the hype because the
moment of course the company is really
an AI company they ask for much higher
valuations so that's why a lot of
business are not try to go and sneak
those words in so they employ one data
scientists who may be actually just was
a bit of very advanced Excel modelling
and they
call it now by doing AI and I think a
lot of investors are still quite nervous
to understand is this not a company that
really knows what they're talking about
is this not this is not really a company
that applies deep algorithms and
understands what they're doing or is it
just one of those hype companies and I
think that's one of the big reasons for
it well what does AI mean to you as an
investor for me it means that you not
just slicing and dicing existing kind of
data but actually that you can kind of
go and start using these data teach it
to kind of go and get information out of
itself and just taking it to the to the
next level to come up with insights that
were previously not there and this is
far more than just slicing and dicing
with data it is taking it to the next
level and for that you need to have some
very very ingrained understanding and
skills and a lot of companies simply do
not have them and but so they use the
buzzword without having the capabilities
and without actually applying it in the
way that it kind of should happen I
think that's where one of the big big
differences on can you just walk us a
little bit on the history of your
company and how you ended up here in
this fairly unique space in terms of in
South Africa or in it's a learning
ending and they are the history of a VC
company sure how I got into VC is
actually quite a funny story
but might be kind of too long I just
wanted to be a VC and there was no
venture capital so I managed to go and
raise a fund from a high net worth
individual the previous found offs of
SAP and that's how can I go and go into
VC our fund itself is now about twelve
years old and it's quite interesting in
South Africa we've got a very very
established actually in Africa private
equity industry everybody wants to go in
that's an infrastructure but when it
comes to investing in technology that's
actually very little a lot of people
still say technology is too risky
early-stage technology is too risk in an
early-stage technology in Africa this
definitely far too risky so therefore if
you kind of go and look at it there is
not much institutional money like in the
u.s. all in the world the VCS I keep
there founded by institutions in Africa
most of them actually founded by high
net worth individuals who are passionate
doesn't have put certain money kind of
into it the problem is that most of
those funds are relatively small so if
you have a 20 million dollar fund in
Africa South Africa this is a huge fund
internationally of course that means
nothing so one of the things is really
how to kind of go and start making the
right investments that don't need ten
fifteen million dollars but that you
need two three million dollars and
really kind of go and take them and we
as a fund have done this now for the
last few years we have just closed our
first fund where we had seven investment
out of the seven investments we had four
exits to global kind of fortune 500
companies
we are one of the few funds who can
really go and say that we have closed
the whole investment cycle investing
everybody can invest the question is can
you make returns out of it and can you
make returns out of it
that not just make you as an investor
happy but make actually the
entrepreneurs and that team is happy as
well because it is it is a long term
journey in venture capital investment
you can't be short-term greedy you have
to be long-term greedy it is a long long
time when you have to kind of go and
work together with companies and yeah
we've done this so if you've closed our
first fund very very successfully on a
high return and now we have busy
investing the second fund and yeah I'm
very very excited to go and see how AI
and ml and how companies of who are
really solving African problems using
this kind of new inside and new
knowledge that actually exists how we
can go and make some cool investments in
that space it's a couple different
questions are coming in my mind right
now but you know one of the things in
particular that I know we talked about
briefly before was how does this compare
startups that you're investing in
compared to those that you've seen out
of like Silicon Valley for example does
that look like so if you think about it
as I just mentioned our funds are
relatively small so if I can only go and
put two or three million dollars into a
company the Silicon Valley counterparts
they get ten million dollars fifteen
million dollars sure we have a slight
cost advantage here in South Africa but
that only applies while we are busy here
in South Africa so the moment we want to
kind of go into business Internet
we still we are traveling everything
still becomes US dollar based and so on
so I think the big point is because our
funds are smaller therefore the amount
per company are smaller our companies
have to become real businesses that's an
advantage and a disadvantage so we
cannot go and take a company that can go
and be not profitable for the next five
years who can just go and employ
employer for people maybe just go and be
very very academic and come up with
amazing results but don't actually have
a real underlying business in Africa in
South Africa our businesses have to
become very very quickly businesses that
are making a profit because there is not
enough money that you can go and pump
into them all the time so therefore
there is a slightly different mindset if
we compare the companies that we invest
into there compared competitors in the
US for example then we quite often see
that they have something even bigger
teams they don't have case studies they
don't work on return of investment did
do a lot of consulting work but actually
I'm not really worried about a be
profitable I'll be making money it's
because there's there's not this kind of
pressure on them because their investors
will just fund it and fund it in our
case we tell them sorry you've got to
three million dollars you have to make
it work at the end of that you need to
be profitable so our business is really
their focus is right begin they have to
employ salespeople they have to employ
our marketing people it it's not just
about the science it's actually about
building a real business that makes
sense mm-hmm I think one of the things
that is always raised I'm especially
when you get to the space of
enterpreneurship and obviously funding
intrapreneurs in Africa is that maybe
the market or the environment is not
ready I can see you maybe not
yes this is this is exactly what I would
like to hear is your opinion of what do
you think is there in the environment
that either has enabled you and your
company to be able to capitalize or what
do you think is there in the Mike Ibarra
actually might inhibit somebody else
coming in with the AVC and investing in
Africa so I think that all the various
ingredients of the ecosystem that is
needed for successful entrepreneurship
the ingredients are there but they are
not linked they are still work
oscillations in some areas and some
little ecosystems it's working closer
together in others it's definitely not
which makes it far more difficult if you
as an investor look to kind of go and
make investment if you just wait for the
perfect business plan to arrive in your
email inbox it's not going to happen so
you need to be out there you need to
kind of go and understand that you will
find a rough diamond and you know you
have to polish it the perfect diamond is
not there so you need to know how to
identify rough diamonds and you need to
understand how to polish that's the
first thing from an entrepreneur point
of view I think maybe because we don't
have enough highly visible success
stories out there they're still not
enough of the real amazing potential
entrepreneurs that are actually deciding
to become entrepreneurs it's still quite
tempting to actually join some of the
big corporates who of course paying much
much better salaries and well then life
is far more secure and it's not that
obvious of how to really go and do is I
think our academic institutions and even
our schools are also not preparing
students early enough to also think
business I think we have a lot of great
specialists but if you want to be an
entrepreneur you also need to be a
generalist you need to understand how to
manage people you need to understand a
bit of finance you need to understand a
bit of sales and marketing so if you are
purely a specialist in a very narrow
area it's quite difficult to kind of go
and and run a business where you have to
be a generalist as well and it's also
trying to kind of go and find the right
diverse team right from the beginning if
you have a group of ten data scientists
they might come up with the most amazing
solutions but I'm not sure where they
come up with an amazing business and I
think so we need to kind of go and start
learning that it's different skills that
are required how do we as a country as a
continent make sure that entrepreneurs
actually have other access to those
skills who have been taught those kind
of skills and then all the other areas
of the ecosystem the rules the
regulations the access to funding all
those kind of things
access to expertise whether it's not
legal accounting all those learnings all
those things need to kind of go and fit
fit together and then I think for the
rest I can definitely say that the
entrepreneurs that I see
absolutely on powers but I see globally
it's the rest that needs to gonna gun
fit that was actually gonna be my next
question to you is that based on what
you've seen so far and in the different
countries that you've been to within the
continent what's goin right what's
working that's making it a good place to
be investing in AI the passion is there
the skills are they siege funding is
oftenly
of is often missing that kind of how to
go and get somebody to take this leap to
actually go and start it not everybody
can afford to not earn a salary for a
for a year's time so how can we kind of
go and close this gap access to market
and understanding how to sell I mean if
your potential client base is a big
corporate well then a lot of people
particularly comes straight from
university they don't know how to do
this they don't understand how to kind
of go and and commercialize the business
so where I see the biggest challenge is
is not when it comes to could they
develop an amazing solution people here
have the deep understanding of the
problems that they want to solve they
can develop the solution what's quite
often missing is I don't know how do I
take this solution to market how do I
get up go and pitch to a big corporate
how do any goes what is the right kind
of pricing for it so the challenge is
really in the how do I go and take a
fantastic solution and build a fantastic
business out of this nothing we need to
support we need to kind of go and come
up with support structures because that
is where things are missing and if I can
go to the US for example some are I
think that gets far more ingrained from
earlier on there's different kind of
support structures there so that just
seems to be a bit more easier maybe also
because there the customer base is far
more used to actually go and speak to
startups where's here
our typical corporates are still yeah
quite reluctant it's the typical nobody
ever gets fired for buying dot dot I
mean it people here rather kind of go
into business with large businesses then
to kind of go and give a start of a real
chance so I think it's those kind of
things it's quite often make a
difference I have two questions actually
that just follow up from there and the
first question is what drives you to do
this work I can tell already that you're
speaking with a lot of passion but like
what drives you to see
do it and to do it here and then the
second one is what I like the specific
examples that I get - you're very
excited to be investing in this space I
come from Germany I could go back to
Germany I need any day and start doing
it there but what I love about this and
what drives me is the fact that they're
amazing challenges here but you can
solve them and you can make an impact
and you can you can see the impact it's
in so many different things and I just
love this I love to work with
entrepreneurs and sometimes one phone
call may can make a difference but
helping with the one little insight it
can make the difference and make a
difference not just to one entrepreneur
but to the whole team to everything so I
love that part I love the fact that here
you can still challenge the status quo
you can break new grounds and I love the
fact that success can stimulate so many
people and here I see so many young
people who really want to go and make a
difference and that could also with the
right skills that could go wherever but
they stay they choose to stay here and
build amazing businesses from Africa to
go and make a difference to be role
models and I think that's what the
country needs and if I can play a tiny
little role there I think that's it's
amazing that's the fun part and I mean I
have children myself yeah I think if we
want to kind of go and prepare the next
future for for the world's lying ahead
of us
well you need to go and invest in
passionate entrepreneurs that's just
what I believe any resources you'd
recommend to those who are trying to
start their own business exploring the
space I think one of the tools that a
lot of people absolutely underestimate
is networking networking networking if
you just go and sit behind your computer
at home and you don't talk to anybody
else you can read as much as you want to
online and that's fine but that's not
going to make it I think people need to
go in and attend conferences like this
and need to go out and you need to go
and find the right communities but also
push themselves out of their comfort
zones to not just kind of go where the
like-minded identical people are and
either kind of go and find out so who
else out there so if you are somebody
who is very very good at data science
you somehow need to find somebody who's
good at commercial try to find those
people try to find out who else is there
I think people need to kind of go
and understand that people buy from
people people invest in people people do
business with people and therefore we
need to kind of go and build the human
touch is important I mean you gotta go
and build closer still wider networks of
different people who can kind of go and
engage help each other because then we
can build all together success stories
so I think it's not so much about what
do I reach and what I do it is about who
do I talk to and how open am I to just
hearing different views because that
might just trigger how to work together
with and how to kind of go and build
long lasting partnerships across across
boundaries across countries across
disciplines because I think that's
what's do you need it that's what makes
a difference any other last bits of
advice that you wanted to share with our
audience just do it I mean I think
there's always a reason not to do it if
you kind of go and want to overthink
things there's always there's always a
reason not to start your own business
it's always a reason to go and play it
safe but you know what this is the time
this is this is the age this is if
there's so many opportunities in them
out there I think people should just
particularly their young just do it well
yelling thank you for helping me and
Andrea thank you this was really
wonderful thank you really great yeah
thank you John thank you for having me
thank you yeah thank you again
yeah seen the cozy and Andrea for all
coming on to the podcast to talk to us
today really appreciate it now it's time
for our question of the week and the
question of the week main takeaways from
the conference and I'll go and I'll kick
this off from the standpoint of what has
been really impressive to me is to see
how much what I see here in terms of
talking to the people that I've talked
to is common across the board
you know the fears of I don't know
enough I'm scared that I in the imposter
syndrome which everyone has but then
still the people who are willing to take
the risk to go into the space has been
really impressive and what's even more
impressive to me about this conference
is how welcoming and inclusive people
are you don't always see that everywhere
and this space can definitely lead to a
very like you don't have enough
sy and Z certain people will have that
attitude but thankfully everyone I've
come across here is just very eager to
open doors just excited to learn and
that's really amazing to me I'm so glad
I was able to come and see that and
experience that and and I'm grateful for
you guys making it so easy for me to be
here so thank you I think for me my key
takeaway really is a question which is
where do we go next and I think as an
organization and as a community we
really have to think very hard about
where are we taking this I mean Africa
has such a huge appetite for machine
learning for AI there is a lot of talent
here Africa of course has all these
challenges which are very unique
globally so I think we will continue to
discuss what is the best way that we can
really strengthen Africa and really make
the world a better place yeah my
takeaway from this it probably is just a
lot of excitement because what
differentiated last year's endeavor from
this year's endeavor is the leap that
the last year Indaba
had on the audience because this time
around what has happened is that people
have come back and people have gone to
transform their lives and the my most
inspired moment was during the metalia
Wars obviously he's one of the people
that is on the podcast and I think he is
inspiring so my takeaway from here this
week is AI in Africa is happening an AI
in Africa can have impact and the impact
we already see the results so there is
no real need for us to doubt believe in
the bigger things that are proposed as
challenges because for as much as they
are challenges there are so many
examples now here that we've seen at the
endeavor of people that have ignored
those challenges and went forward and
built AI and AI tools to improve African
lives yeah Billy let me ask you any
where you're gonna be next other than
sleeping soon
yes I think for the immediate future I'm
just gonna go back to my own lab here at
Stellenbosch a lot of my students
attended the Indaba
and I'm sure they were all really
excited and inspired by everything that
I've experienced and I'm looking forward
to just chatting to them and seeing
where can we take our own research next
then of course we also have another
machine learning Summer School in
Stellenbosch happening in January and
yeah we have a few exciting new programs
also in development at stellenbosch in
machine learning and artificial
intelligence thank you yelling what
about you yes I guess the first thing
that will is probably going to happen is
we will probably get to Ghana so there
will be that move and then for the
actual machine learning community I will
be in Montreal in December with the
women in machine learning will be at
nips I'm one of the co-organizers of the
women in machine learning there so we're
running the workshop yes and I think
besides that and there's going to be a
month without Indaba and so there'll be
a month of sleep like a good month well
alright so in terms of the usual with
mark and myself we will both be at
Strange Loop next week and so you should
come and say hi to us if you're gonna be
there outside of that we'll share more
about where we're gonna be next week
thank you both again
yelling Billy I really appreciate you
both joining me on the podcast and
helping me put this together thank you
thank you thank you to you Melanie
[Music]